19h45 on est en direct quel bonheur de
vous retrouver les chalets on m'avait
énormément ce manque t ce week end à ce
manque est un grand corps a étonné tout
ça
et tu fais partie de mes cinq meilleurs
potes dans le métier avec gaston bien
entendu et cabaye a maintenant un vrai
ça y est ma vente et brême était un jour
là tu es toujours là et matt pokora en
fait il était là pour moi avant même que
je fasse de la télé c'est ça c'est pour
ça qu'il aime sa première fois c'est
2006 de ses barons certaines missions où
on avait chanté ensemble elle me
contrôle d'ailleurs c'est vrai j'étais
magnifique sur tf 1 2 million je suis
très heureux pour toi parce que ça
cartonne et j'ai un cadeau pour toi mon
chéri des choix regarde des triple
disque de platine
[Applaudissements]
y'a une bonne question de pascal persie
pascal moi c'est un truc qui m'a vexé
c'est papa pourra aussi parce que
j'avais défendu mâts par rapport à ce
qui s'est passé avec matt androni ça ça
m'a énormément quand on connaît son
parcours je trouvais ça alors on va y
travailler on va rappeler entre cavalia
n'a qu'à moi ouais c'est ça oui
écoute la vie dure en fait non là là où
elle fait fausse route c'est alors après
que qu'elle mérite ça il ya aucun
problème
moi je pense juste là où elle a fait une
erreur c'est quand elle parle de top 10
ouais c'est ça c'est quoi le club y
compris ming dans le top10 streaming j'y
suis pas mais par contre je vais pas
commenter le top-10 physique qui suivit
du plus important c'est ça le top 10 de
retourner j'y suis depuis 17 ans
donc en fait cia est en fait il faut il
ya juste deux générations la qui
s'opposent en fait entre guillemets
c'est à une opposition de d'un public
d'une génération wave tic qui a commencé
en 2003 et un public qui est là depuis
trois ans qui est très stream
matt pokora y écrit pas une chanson sur
maps et un bond à l'agonie dit khalid tu
crois quoi on était tous les deux
pyramides de lure pas de se promener les
bras je fais pas une champions serait
pyramide on est comme ça matt pokora et
moi d'ailleurs il sera encore là et tout
dans un instant en duplex je pas le
lâcher on est comme ça
hanouna pokora hanouna pokora
chekhchoukha c'est pareil très inspirant
et là c'est que six mois vous avez la
réputation à très inspirant ah oui bah
vous allez voir très attention en une
petite tête demain ça vous inspire
avec le calendrier alors est ce que j'ai
à faire le 12 mai là
alors moi qui adore les chevaux j'adore
celle là mais je suis un amoureux de
l'équitation cheval même à poney je suis
comme un fou c'est à dire agir connu la
ses flibustiers sa cinquième bougie dans
la deuxième à clara le calendrier de
clara morgane
j'en rigolais tu l'attends c'est comme
quand tu attends le pin le ton petit
navire on dirait qu'ils arrivent en
bateau était au port comme ça et un
petit faible pour le temps que tu n'es
vraiment le calendrier
alors ça c'est clair
bien entendu en garder qu'un magnifique
bouquet de roses et derrière on a
regardé comme ses beaux yeux dans les
yeux je lui ai posé la question et il
m'a dit il je vous assure je peux pas
vous jurés parce que je ne jure pas je
suis pas croyant mais je vous assure que
je n'ai pas violer nafissatou diallo je
peux pas vous en dire plus et vous le
croyez et donc je le crois je le crois
et je crois aussi ce que raconte
nafissatou diallo je crois les deux
parce que les deux versions
à mon sens ne sont pas incompatibles
dominique strauss kahn a commis une
forme d'abus de position dominante
c'est à dire que cette femme elle rentre
dans cette chambre elle le voit nue elle
est là est lui bien elle sait que c'est
le directeur général du fmi parce que
des petites fiches en bas elle sait
exactement qu'il dans la suite
présidentielle c'est le personnage le
plus puissant de l'hôtel en sommes très
important et sait pas encore qu'il est
français et qui peut être président
république en france mais c'est que
c'est un homme très puissant et quand il
fait ce geste elle est tétanisée elle
n'est d'ailleurs quand elle dit que il
prend les seins elle aurait pu se sauver
elle aurait pu la porter de martel peut
s'endetter texan va pas elle est
tétanisée
elle est paralysée et s'exécute à ses
ordres en fait parce qu elle est
tétanisée par l'un via l'imposition de
certaines donc je me sens devenir le
moral
mais quand je regardais les petits pois
rouges leur faut ni de regard du poids
on dit par ici et là et la donne ouais
aulas
c'est toujours toujours le relais voire
plus tôt
rien
rozès j'achète havre l'info du jour si
vous nous rejoignez la chérie 7 millions
qu'est ce que c'est lisa et moi j'en
déduis qu'il vaut mieux de sa copine que
sa femme parce que 7 millions mais ça me
fait de la peine c'est mignon c'est ce
qu'il a donné à ses ex femmes benjamin
castaldi nous avons marié vous avec
benjamin déjà les gagner ah oui alors il
faut déjà battre benjamin il a toujours
dit et c'est pour ça que quand il dit la
vérité il a toujours dit que cela devait
faire il avait gagné présent bien sûr
voilà pour jouer vous remercier c'est
que effectivement l'émission parce que
ça a changé mon image dans ce sens assez
concernés pour à mes côtés un jeu que
j'ai jamais été pas du tout et on en
parle c'est de fait on après avec la
chaîne tout à l'heure c'est que j'ai
fait une grosse erreur c'est quand je
suis avec sur celui de la première fois
pour faire de belles stars j'ai refusé
de venir l'émission mais par connerie
par lots j'ai pas du tout on s'est
engueulés encore qu'on en deux ans pour
rien sur voilà maintenant qu on fait
mais je me dis aux téléspectateurs mais
vous paraît sympa cela padura jamais
même à l'époque un vrai que ça raconte
épaules mais j'avais une image terrible
après je n'ai pas été aidé les ige dit
camille combal aimerait beaucoup animé
les nrj music awards
ah c'est vrai oui nikos il est un petit
peu bousculé sur l'énergie médicaux je
vous dis ce qui va se passer l'année
prochaine je pense que nikos d'affaires
les miss france camille combal va faire
l'énergie et jean-pierre va annoncer que
c'est sa dernière sur les 100 ans de
miss france ça ne serait pas bonne à
dire parce que je suis fan de jean
pierre foucault mais je sens est très
bien j'ai eu aucune approche de dire aux
téléspectateurs mais je sens le truc et
le noël lorette
ceux qui connaissent pas bien le foot
c'est le président de la fédération
française de football est ce que vous
trouvez ces propos hypocrites contaminé
s'il n'y a pas de racisme
oui mais je pense que ces personnes ne
font plus de la politique ou du frais si
c'est ça ouais donc aujourd'hui ces
jeunes là ils ont pas ils quittent pas
le périph y sortent pas du périph
ouais c'est moi je fais beaucoup
d'études aujourd'hui sur des clubs
parisiens
c'est catastrophique c'est ce qui a fait
que donner des exemples à nos
téléspectateurs mais viry-châtillon par
un super club à viry-châtillon quelques
personnes de la fédération les condamne
pour quatorze mille euros il dit
deux divisions alors que c'est déjà
inquiets du que les enfants passent
quand vous parlez surtout d'éducation
déjà on le laisse comme ça il n'y a pas
de bien mais il n'y a pas de on n'a pas
les voir et dans ces jeunes de leur tour
d'ivoire prennent des décisions sans
connaître le football et sans connaître
surtout les ducs ce qui se passe dans
les clubs et il paraît qu'il est très
jaloux emmanuel macron oui mais avec moi
j'étais aussi avec ses collaborateurs
après avec ses collaborateurs des sas
moutons politique
ouais il a peur qu'on lui refasse le
coup qu'il a fait à hollande je sorte à
dire il a peur qu'ils aient une tête qui
dépasse donc il fait attention que il
n'y a pas des gens qui aiment trop
difficile redouter une percée politique
de benjamin griveaux on a vu le benjamin
griveaux avait percé mais pas en
politique c'est vrai ça pour percer la
percée bas il est tranquille maintenant
j'ai l'impression qu'en toi tu fais un
truc qu'on comprend pas que c'est un
sketch
non c'est paris c'est qu'on ne veut pas
accepter un déjà que c'est un sketch et
2 potentiellement que ça peut être drôle
moi ce que je veux dire aujourd'hui
c'est le règne des attachés de presse et
des bulles immobilières dans l'humour
c'est à dire que d'un coup on dit à cet
humoriste fatiou va bien tu les reçoit à
il est hyper marrant au bout de deux ans
n'entend plus parler de lui c'est un
retour des années yéyé souvient le mec
qui sortent un vinyle mais d'un coup se
disent ébahis où le mec qui chantait la
danse des canards on n'a plus de
nouvelles depuis quarante deux ans bien
sûr gratuit et voilà il ya ne l'a vécu
moi je suis hyper heureux d'être avec
une folie parce qu'elle a traversé le
temps oui et je n'aime pas ces discours
qui disent ah oui mais ça c'est pas bien
en fait en france tu peux pas être
populaire à partir de tulle a vécu à
dire que d'un coup tu as des gens qui
disent si les gens aiment c'est que
c'est pas bon pour nous bruno mérine
merci d'être là nous vous en prie
en plus si on a un petit antilles en est
on connaît une perte nette de personnes
en commun tous les deux c'est vrai et
oui mon père au travers et oui mon père
qui vous êtes vous êtes vous un coach
qui vous habite à côté tu mon père mes
voisins et paraître mon père vous
emmerde parce qu'il garde toujours sa
voiture sur un parking à villa park inn
commun avec le avec le mien bien
d'accord ça va il m'ennuie pas du tout
il est sympa et très discrète mais très
discret travers de son fils vous
concernant pendant des années à dire que
mon père était mort comme ça c'était
plus simple ah ouais ça vide et sam
éviter d'avoir des réponses alors après
les gens me demandaient de commandes
était mort etc
alors des fois je fais du groupe pop
rock music zag et ça passait quoi mais
c'est compliqué le plus dur c'est à dire
la vérité en fait que quand on est le
gamin et quand on nous dit qu'on n'a pas
leur dire la vérité on fait comment quoi
quand son papa et tout en cavale comment
vous voyez quand vous arrivez à le voir
comment vous ne serez pas parler comment
tu vas arriver à le voir elle sera dans
mon livre c'est ouais sera retenu mais
non tu as changé il n'y a pas
possibilité non plus un voeu pieux
produit risque que peu de données à ce
qui est juste ce que pouvait bien ce
qu'ils prenaient des risques pour vous
voir pour vous voir ses enfants oui oui
oui oui mais pas deux fois deux fois
mais cette fois il était déguisé
forcément comme moi je vais une fois je
l'avais pas reconnu alors bien sûr
badoit gars arrivent et avec plus ou
moins dépanneur en fin de compte le
dépanneur c'était mon père
[Musique]